on y va tu attends calais comme ça ne
choque quand même même en tentant pas
toc toc toc voilà on s'est dit on sait
qu'on sait qu'on sait que c'est mal
prononcé donc à votre avis c'est qui oui
mais non c'est qu'alors europe et au toc
toc toc qui et séguy piqué qu'il y met
guillemets guillemets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cast a dit c'est bon merci merci merci
merci et bravo
merci pour benji est là attention au
deuxième acte à knox est partie à la
haye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ce alors c'est la musique après
qu'elle l'ait dit y ont peu en régime
en fait tu vas tu peux leur faire tout
ce que tu veux mon bébé isabelle wii ne
partent pas bébé musique rom était là
je vous
isabelle taitt ray-ban isaba chez iqt à
l'heure en loge
mais jacques thomas très bien non mais
comme ça je sais avant tu avais des jeux
comme ça toujours que c'est vrai pour
ceux qui connaissent pas isabelle elle
avait les jeux comme ça avant elle avait
fait appel et c'est vrai elle avait joué
je les dis la draft dans ta touche
m'étouffe merci à balma si on vous
demandera quand quelque chose est drôle
et parfois aller toc toc toc
non c'est moi qui fais alors il aux
toques non ces trois fois à bon alors
toc toc toc pierre par trois fois
toc toc toc mais non faut faire toi
fadoq par tonne alors qui c'est andy
andy qui ont duré deux ans habile
[Applaudissements]
key
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
les regards dans rabbi jacob lui annaba
avec misco rigoler mais hassaballah non
pas du tout merci à sa place non pas du
tout pas du tout aller toc toc toc
emma et maquille les magnolias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'hirondelles sais pas quoi
tous jouer là bas
bravo
non maintenant pour retirer votre toof
oui c'est vrai merci greg claudette de
l'époque
c'est vrai c'est vrai que sans rien n'a
été moulues au feu de bois à les
prochains toc toc toc c'est parti toc
toc
non enfin non en fait non wick et là
c'était au toqué
théo kate hiver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
en
un mec dans le gang des postiches
mais sans déconner on dirait métier mais
tu vas tu yeux dégueulasse mais c'est
bouclé il était bon maxime est très bon
et un corps de padel de pattes d'eph
mais saint-céré fait petit cuisse tous à
la haye a passé quand il est là trois
petites cuisse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
ok
project octobre c'est parti mais tu es
venu vente du poisson faire attention
alors on l'a fait tac tac tac qu'il sait
ayem à yanji
[Applaudissements]
à c
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bravo kennedy ce qu a été inventé
sans rigoler c'est un truc de ouf ça
jamais autant donné à j'ai adoré non
mais sans déconner c'est un truc et
cette coiffure
oui ça ne va pas mais le sait ça m'a
quand même est franchement qu'elle a
donné de la foule
j'ai adoré c'était à refaire vous ne
m'avez gâter leur a offert ouais allez
vas-y fais-le
[Applaudissements]
il
non
[Applaudissements]
ouais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette nouvelle
danse vous fait à chaque fois maintenant
comme ça c'est fou comme ça me vient
comme ça ça vient comme ça c'est un truc
en toi il faut que ça reparte c'est
l'étude sûr on vous êtes au niveau du
pic du coeur ouais mais le rythme et sa
non celle qui n'a fait des faits la
vérité
alors vous savez que sur twitter jeudi
sur les réseaux sociaux il ya beaucoup
de gens qui disent est ce qu'il se
passerait pas un truc entre mathieu
équipe américaine aurait dit on dirait
qu'elle est barbu miliana qui a envie de
canal au garden non mais on va l'avoir
maintenant il ya un an alors ce qui est
vrai alors alors c'est important pour
l'été c'est quand on est une famille on
allait en dessous alors ce qui est droit
comptera aussi laventure d'isabelle
morini-bosc avec papy brossard il n'y a
rien de plus beau que quelqu'un qui est
beau et qu'il ne sait pas elle est
magnifique elle est douce elle est
gentille ça de doral et ty télé t'es con
y'en 100 caractères j'aime bien le plus
cher de sa peau son odeur je peux pas
cacher que c'est très nouveau chez moi
il ya eu il ya un effet physique bien
sûr c'est très étonnant
et alors me 1 1 et alors je voulais
j'aime beaucoup on s'est vus on s'est vu
un petit peu dans les loges on s'est
rapprochés mais rapprochée c'est à dire
bah c'est à dire qu'un alors je vous
raconte ça mais attention pas de paddle
soit on ne dira pas la télé
on me dira devant la télé avec cet effet
sortira pas de la france non
consentement total à chauray dans la
loge maquillage la noce en eau de pont
se changer à la fermer le rideau
bon bah cabine et je lui dis donc qu'est
ce que tu fais je me change la vision
tulle est très belle elle me va bien je
rentre dans la cabine et vous dis bien a
les seins nus dijon c'était une poitrine
magnifique clément et elle me dit si tu
veux mais bon si tu veux tu peux toucher
donc je pars dans le jeu oui non ce
n'est pas le bon exode touch est
effective et c'est effectivement jeu ça
ça et ça a provoqué chez aux choses elle
est magnifique aventure sortie de cette
cabine assez rapidement mais c'est vrai
ou pas non si je peux avoir mon droit de
parole c'est vrai que mathieu à la peau
très douce ouais bon à la fin de vie
dont il y prend peine de certains crimes
commis sont perdus mais ça marche et
c'est vrai que mathieu je le considère
vraiment comme une copine comme enjeu
[Applaudissements]
jeu avec moi jamais mais je sais mais
avec moi que si oui jamais c'est non
seulement mathieu non banon mais maxime
mais jamais de la vie rutte s'est
vraiment dit la vérité du bon côté de la
rivière tu seras avec moi pas du tout à
être et ben j'ai une bonne nouvelle il
est passé de placebo
soyez prêts à passer de l'autre côté de
la rivière pour kelly a pour kelly en
tout cas prêts pour québec versé 1 tu
fais pas de ça je me forcerai pas mon
jeu terme et kelly est ce que vous
maintenant ce n'est pas telle autre côté
d'arriver à ce que vous posez la
question de chance de rivières n'ont ils
pas un peu trop chaud ou bien le change
de rivière ouelle et pas trop vieux avec
les schémas nyfix charismatique et
n'essaie pas de casser le cou trois
semaines j'espère que tout le monde doit
prouver une balade de nom mais kelly est
ce que si il fait le show man je lui ai
dit à romain ce médian plus avoir même
mais je lui ai dit que s'il était pas
non mais oui mais c'est pas si il peut
il peut changer les mots exacts et l'a10
manquons ath ans elle m'a dit j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils me fassent l'amour
[Applaudissements]
je lui dis déjà d'ailleurs on s'en fout
du lait chaud mais dit une chose c'est
vrai
si arrêté ma salle voilà non mais alors
qu'elle y est si si si si l'amour et
vous et qui veut changer on peut changer
abbas il veut changer moi je jouis roi
jade moi je moi je vous dire par exemple
au nom des charges peut très bien
prendre une banane abricots mais non je
ne change pas je parlais fruits mois
jusqu'à fruitiers non mais c'est vrai
que je pense la même chose et mathieu il
est aussi bonne en rénovation on vous a
posé une question
mais si demain mathieu vous dit il vient
vous voir et vous dit kelly s'est
terminée voilà j'ai trouvé en toi la
femme de ma vie
ouais est ce qu'on peut vivre une
aventure ensemble s'il est sûr de son
changement de blainville et sur wii il
est sûr mais il est bas oui alors alors
alors on va faire l'amour ou quoi non
mais mathieu alors timide au début mais
c'est possible ou pas bah c'est possible
allez moi je suis estate dont j'ai
toujours dit que je pourrais faire une
très jolie fille et un garçon étaient
très bien j'aime ce qui est beau merci
gérald nrj 12 elle est belle
physiquement c'est une belle personne et
c'est vrai que en ce moment je suis très
enfants non je ne juge pas je peux le
dire oui géraldine châtia été sur les
deux rives tu as fait les femmes est
d'habitude mais un sujet vingt-et-une
fille a déjà vu est ce que tu as déjà eu
une aussi belle chance et que kelly non
je reconnais et je reconnais souvent
quand les filles étaient très joli et le
minot d un peu le magasin kelly et les
do samba centre glen
on va suivre ça ouais dé très près parce
que je vais mettre des caméras chez vous
et on verra ça allez c'est parti
le poste attaqué octobre ceylan qui
hélas s'émousse mosquée
ce qui la subissent ou semi s'émousse
ministre entre mousse qui nous sont les
femmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas dedans c'est lui ouais
c'est vrai alors que c'est le danseur
s'annonce très bien oui non c'est très
bien de danse bien qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous faire une petite danse une
vraie avec avec isabelle quoi au tour
maintenant chaque fois bah oui allez
vous voulez donc ou pas bien sûr c'est
sûr qu'elle aussi discours il ne l ai
pas dis allez venez isabelle hallé valeo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis quitté le parquet c'est pas mal
ça c'est nouveau ça je ne lis pas la
presse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle elle le regarde et on avait
l'impression qu'elle avait vu un truc
leslie mann à ce que tu vois pas qu'il
faut le noeud martyrisé habitat 17 jan
tarif vous a aidé les gestions des
gentils noms du show détonnant
alors s est votre style moi j'adore doc
mairie mais sinon c'est votre style bas
avec l'échauffement on sait pas si
méchant que lui je ne dis rien mais on
dirait à l'époque en tant qu'acteur
c'est parti toc toc toc weekend in hell
bilal qui pinel pinel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginent demain quand tu vas aller
livrer chez les super plaisir de revoir
la montée en débit note c'est parti ça
m'a énormément aidé en rien c'est aline
tissot à linky voilà alignant pib
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'événement va y perdre au japon c'est
magnifique c'est vrai ça vous paraît
mais comme ça mais vrai sur l a déjà dit
elle a déjà des étoiles dans les yeux le
regard le regard ça va marcher en pleine
forme même temps de te voir
oui bon il m'avait manqué à toi aussi
qu'est ce qui vous est si peu importe le
montant des traîtres c'est la seule
botte même en boîte de nuit à nous
parler comme ça prête noms mais canton
de vaud revoir à l'est le dernier le
dernier qui manque à cette table puis
milan michel mr c'est parti et toc toc
toc vas-y c'est jean michel tu fais quoi
la peinture aura après oui alors
justement avant on va parler famille
matinée jean missionnaire jean michel
maire qui était en toc toc toc m'a dit
jean michel d'hooghe qui est assise à
dix qui disent frêche
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire je veux dire je vais
le dire une bonne fois pour toutes je
vous le dis si non mais je vous le dis
c'est ça suffit nous serons ok mais ça
suffit c'est devenu une habitude pour
tout le monde
tout le monde se frottent je ne suis pas
un tampon gex alors allez-y c'est mon
père c'est jean-michel
[Applaudissements]